what's happening you bad [__]
it's monday the 11th of october
the joint is brought to you and proud to
introduce our brand new sponsor
liquid iv
let me tell you something right now is
the time
to be tip top magoo on your vitamins up
your gym
everything it's flu season and god knows
what else is out there support your
immune system with the proper hyde
hydration and vitamins one stick of
liquid iv in just 16 ounces of water
hydrates faster and more efficiently
than water alone let me tell you
something you got to try the lemon lime
it's tremendous healthier than those
overpriced sugary sports drinks no
artificial flavors or perturbatives and
less sugar than an apple you cannot beat
it all right made with clean
ingredients and they're supporting
front-line workers to stay healthy
liquid iv has donated 11 million
servings
so far the hospitals ems's food banks
veterans and active military do me a
favor grab your favorite liquor iv
flavors nationwide at walmart or get it
delivered like i do get 25 percent off
when you go to liquid iv.com
and use promo code joey to check out
again
that's 25 off anything you order
get better hydration today using promo
code joey
liquid iv.com
the joint is also brought to you by one
of my personal [__] favorites
manscaped fall is in the air and some of
you [__] are still walking
around
with julia serving between your legs
listen i know it's halloween and you're
looking to scare [__] but
that's a little too scary you're gonna
scare [__] women away you gotta trim
your [__] pubes
you know what i'm saying you gotta get
that pumpkin balls
nice and [__] ready for halloween
bundle up with the manscape performance
package you've heard me talk about it
before
it's the package has everything you're
gonna get the lawnmower trimmer 4.0 with
ceramic blade it's precise you only cut
hairs no ball sacks it's waterproof and
it's got a [__] led spotlight you got
more features than a swiss army knife
but there's more the performance packet
has the weed whacker nose and earhead
trimmer the crop preserver ball
deodorant the crop revival my all-time
favorite you can use it under your eyes
for your bags and the performance box of
briefs and a travel bag to carry it all
the performance package 4.0
is [__] global what does that mean
joey you get in the usa canada uk europe
australia south africa singapore
wherever the [__] you go
manscaped is there i love manscape
i keep my balls [__] nice and shaved
the area around the [__] joystick is
nice and shaved and remember if you
shave around your dick your dick looks
bigger don't be a [__] jerk off think
about it get 20 percent off and free
worldwide shipping today at manscape.com
joey that's manscape.com
joey 20 off and free worldwide shipping
at manscape.com
joey no more [__] disgusting pubic
hairs with manscape
all right let's get this party started
on the monday [__] morning
welcome to uncle joy's joy
[Music]
what's happening you bad [__]
it's monday the 11th of october holy
[__]
it's [__] flying the leaves are
changing [__] colors
i'm [__] excited they're falling all
over the place
it's been great it was a great [__]
weekend uh i did not watch the wilder
fight i don't i don't know nothing about
boxing everybody was calling me he was
gonna win i got no idea about boxing i
pressed the link to draftkings it was a
good weekend for draftkings you had pro
baseball playoffs you had [__]
college football you had ufc
mackenzie dern lost with that beautiful
[__] muffler you had [__] uh you
know deontay wild whatever his [__]
name is you had a full [__] flan
weekend
if you're a sports [__] fanatic i
didn't watch dick
i didn't watch the ufc i didn't watch
[__] i watched kids [__] games i went
to
jimmy florentine sons basketball game
and then i did something i didn't think
i was gonna do
and i [__]
this week i watched two movies that were
[__] tremendous
like i watched three movies that were
i watched a new movie with john bernthal
called small engine repair
which was [__] tremendous movie my
type of movie
small cast
old school buddy movie that's what it is
about three old friends you know great
[__] movie but i watched
boogie nights it's been on every night
this week you got to watch the boogie
nights one of the greatest [__]
movies
of all time hands down
underrated as [__] and then i watched
another underrated film i know it did
great in the box office and [__]
the wolf of [__] wall street holy
[__]
i watched you know i hadn't seen it
since and came out and then i had jordan
uh whatever on the [__] uh you know
on the podcast and we discussed it
man i watched that movie the other day i
tell you what i had to turn it the [__]
off
because i was getting flashbacks in 19
[__] 70s and 80s i swear to god
those quaaludes guys were no joke i i'm
so [__] happy
that they're gone i'm not gonna listen
guys i'm not gonna lie to you i'll never
eat another xanax i'll never eat another
pain pill
i'll never eat another [__] hit of
acid i'll keep smoking my dope
and i'll keep doing my little edibles at
night
i don't ever want to do cocaine i don't
ever want to drink
but if you got a quail
i'm coming over
i swear to god i'm being honest as i can
with you [__]
if you got a quaalude i'm coming over
while i was sitting there i was thinking
about
all the [__] mishaps with quaaludes
like quaaludes would not make it in a
co-video [__] world right now
because let me tell you something right
now look
ever since the pandemic started we've
had some bad luck my friend broke his
ankle jumping rope he's a boxer you know
how the [__] do you break your ankle
jumping [__] rope but
you know it's just been some weird
accidents bert
tom there's been some weird [__] [__]
let me tell you something when cuellar
joined my life i always had a bruise
like i always had a bruise or a black
eye
when i was doing quaaludes i always had
a [__] condition a bruise on my leg
you just fall you fall you drop glasses
you [__] get into fist fights you
fall off your bicycle you know you just
did [__] that
you know like i told you guys and i i'm
really sorry about this
one day you know because i would i would
sell quaaludes as a hustle quaaludes
were a great hustle listen
you know these people investment
opportunities go [__] yourself let me
tell you something the best investment
was quaaludes 100 quality for 200 and
you sold them for four dollars and you
got 400 bucks you made 200 bucks
in two hours
i would sell 200 100 [__] gorilla
biscuits in two [__] hours they were
missing like an hour or something like
the lemon missed an l oh my god people
went crazy over those those bootleg ones
you have no idea an ecstasy listen
quaalude was replaced by ecstasy if you
know the evolution of [__] drugs some
people are going to argue with me but
you can't [__] win think of how it
changed it went from quaaludes
right to [__] ecstasy and no the
quaaludes disappeared like in 83
84 was when i stopped seeing gorilla
biscuits by 85 they were [__] gone i
don't know
when those other designer drugs started
popping up on the [__] thing
molly started coming up and all that
[__] so there you have it there was a
little gap people were like what the
[__] happened to quaaludes we got to
come up with something else
some people started licking frogs and
[__] some people you know eating
mushrooms but the [__] quaalude left
a gap
that was so i mean when i had jordan on
the show the wolf of wall street
he even like the look on his face
the sweetness of quality cocaine was one
thing
you know going out to clubs was another
but man
when you ate a [__] quaalude
everything changed i mean i've got
i remember one night i was at this kid
we were at a party i was young
i had to be in the eighth grade i was
not eating quaaludes then he had eaten a
quaalude he was a little older than me
and we were walking and he just stopped
he goes hold on i got to do something he
just stopped and put his hand through a
[__] glass
like i i don't know what made me tell
you guys this story
but it affected people like in different
[__] ways like he i'll never forget
he put his hand through the [__]
glass i don't know what he was mad about
i don't know what it made him do you
always hear about quaaludes that people
were [__] giving them like cosby was
giving them to chicks and [__] i could
look you [__] in the eye
and tell you one thing i never gave him
to somebody to dose him if i gave him to
a chick if i was with a chick and i had
a quaalude i'd ask her do you want to
eat a [__] half a biscuit before she
ate it i'd tell her the [__] riot act
listen if you eat this
it's going to be all over but the shot
i'm going to end up [__] eating a
little monkey or something bad is going
to happen
and they would go what are you going to
do you know what i'm saying at least you
knew what was that's what the woman was
in 1980. women have changed the [__]
lot in 40 [__] years because you know
you call you show up to a woman now and
you want to do a roofie or something
that's against a lot what the [__] are
you talking about we're just having a
good time i'm get it's not like i'm
sprinkling it and putting in your
[__] uh
soda or your cocktail i'm offering it to
you do you want to do a [__] biscuit
i was honest with people so if you want
to do a biscuit let's [__] do a
biscuit
man
i used to on friday nights me and my
buddy renee
used to [__]
every friday for about a year my junior
year in high school every friday night
we would meet up like at 6 00 7 30
go get a [__] bottle of pupa vodka
that [__] p-o-p-o-v poop off
we would mix it with gatorade
and [__] and in the winter being
outside
we need a [__] lemon or aurora 714
express
and we go back to his apartment and we
listen to [__] led zeppelin three
the immigrant not the immigrant song
gallows poll
over and over and over and over and over
we'd be drinking the [__] vodka
with and if we had dough like if we had
dough we'd get the smirnoff silver
that [__] was good smearing off silver
and we [__] wait for his brother to
come home i remember being like 16
and we would wait for his brother to
come home his brother would come home
like a 3 15
we'd be at the top the bottom half of
the [__] quaalude
and then we tell his brother you got to
give us a line of coke he goes i'll give
you a line of coke on one condition that
you get the [__] out of here i got a
girl coming over here
done
did we do the [__] line of coke and
that would be me and him we were like 16
we were [__] two jerk clothes we just
walk around but when i tell you that the
society had everybody had them
like this was something that everybody
had you know people have rolling papers
like you go up so you got everybody's
got [__] rolling papers
everybody had biscuits when you went out
i remember vividly
vividly
going to the b-52 concert
on new year's eve
at the ritz or one of those [__]
clubs in the city
and we each had two [__] gorilla
biscuits
you would either half
test the waters
have a few cocktails
do a few bumps have another half and
then you would dose as the night went on
you know what i'm saying like you would
take a couple [__] pieces or a half
let me tell you something we went to
that [__] b-52 concert i ate a
[__] i think the concert started like
at nine or something like that or ten
i ate a [__] quail and you didn't
really know where the quail was gonna
take you sometimes you ate a [__]
biscuit and it would be slow
and then you'd eat the other one and the
full pill would hit you and you're like
[__]
i made a mistake
but
most of the time you know like you just
ate it and it was all even but there was
two types of quails there were the
pharmaceutical ones
and then you know you know how these
[__] kids are people started making
the bootleg ones the bootleg ones
weren't bad but the problem with the
bootleg ones like i said on rogan years
ago if the table was bent like for some
reason if the [__] apartment was old
or the garage was old where they were
doing the quaaludes and the floor was
little off when they put the pills down
and they put the [__] chemicals on
them the chemicals would run down to the
lower 40.
so the top 60 would be mediocre so if
you bought one of the top 60s
you would get like medium high but then
if you bought one of the bottom 40s you
get double high so your prayer with the
[__] bootlegs was to eat a [__]
the top 61 but to also get your hands on
a 41
and hopefully it would work out at some
point in the night if you opened up with
the 60 you wouldn't get that high and
you'd be kind of pissed off what the
[__] is going on with the quaalude it's
not hitting me i'm not dropping glasses
yet so [__]
you'd have to hit the 40 like a half and
make sure because if you [__] ate the
whole 40
and the whole 60 like one night i ended
up
at a [__] chinese
bodega i ended up in the [__] hallway
of the bodega
like i [__] woke up with a hooded
sweatshirt guys it had to be january 20
something
19 [__] 80 81
it was freezing out i was so high i
didn't even make it down the [__]
corner i'm sorry guys i'm lucky i didn't
lose a finger too or a nose or an ear
that night because i slept outside
basically when i woke up in the morning
i was [__] crooked and [__]
thank god i had a couple dollars in me
there was a chinese what it wasn't a
chinese restaurant it was called dragon
grocery i knew the people they were half
cuban half chinese every sunday they
cooked [__] chinese food it was
tremendous the daughter was hotter than
[__]
i would go in there and torture the
chinese guy all the time i would do this
to him
that means go [__] your mother in
chinese i don't know what it means they
don't like it though he would [__]
chase us and [__] you put two fingers on
top of the other one you go
and they [__] go crazy well he used
to go crazy i don't know what it meant
somebody told me to do it to him one day
i did it to me he chased me down the
block with a [__] spatula
you know so i i always [__] with him
so i don't know what made me go
into the [__] uh little chinese
hallway there i thought he was open to
something there's no [__] way he was
open
and i just fell asleep in that [__]
thing i swear to god when i woke up the
next morning i needed a 15 [__]
chiropractor but i didn't give a [__] in
fact
one of the kids i saw last night which
we'll get to two nights ago saturday
night he was the one i was with
uh
saturday night i did something i didn't
think i would do in a long time
you know i'm from north bergen and since
i've gotten off the [__] plane here
last august i've been to north bergen
like i've been up there a couple times i
see some people and stuff like that
but it got to the point where i'm like
i'm depending too much on north bergen
you know for me uh
having friends and [__] i got to make
friends down here
you know so i said to myself i'm going
to give myself the summer off not go up
there i didn't go up north all [__]
summer i went up north to
to do the premiere on the 22nd of
september and before that i hadn't been
up that way in a long [__] time
i hadn't been up there since probably
april or [__] maybe
so i did you know they invited me was
the carnival in north berlin um
they do it every year my buddy anthony
is in charge of the park and and my
other buddy devo and you know he does
the park also so they both reached out
to me and they said you know my bad my
friend's band was playing up there
and uh steven avila i've had him on the
podcast the past masters
and i didn't know i didn't know what to
expect i didn't know if i really wanted
to do it or not
all week long i didn't know if my
daughter was going to have games it was
going to [__] rain on saturday
you know so i said [__] it you know what
i'll just play it by [__] here
saturday morning i woke up i had to take
mercy to kick boxing we did a few
[__] things
i went to a kid's party
jimmy florentine's son had a basketball
game i went over there it looked like it
was going to rain it was a shitty
[__] day down here
so i'm like what the [__] am i gonna do
so we were at a party and the guy opened
up his pool believe it or not the
[__] pool was 91 degrees on saturday
it wasn't that hot out it was cloudy it
looked like it was gonna rain but he
threw the [__] heater on they were
over there watching penn state iowa and
[__] so
my daughter stayed over there in the
pool my wife stayed over there they were
happy
i went back from the [__] thing and a
buddy of mine called me i called him
about two days ago
something just made me think about him i
know he he lost his mom
about two years ago i was tight with him
and his mom and his brother and his
sister
and i had not seen him since 1993.
we
text from time to time we talk from time
to time
he was a dear friend of mine i mean uh
from the time we were 14
we were brothers man we breathe for one
another i mean
me him roger holloway and fernie besuto
were unseparable when we were kids from
probably
i don't know july of 81 to [__]
december of 85 we were
always connected at the [__] hip uh
roger died last year
ferny has lost you know fernie
gambled when we were younger and uh
it took him for a [__] loop he never
recovered from that so the only two guys
that are left from that group is myself
and glenn you know and we guys we went
through a lot together and i even had to
remind them last saturday night
when we were eating what we've been
through together i mean as as friends
you know we were both
you know he came from a home that uh
single mom the whole thing
busting her ass from uh glenn has worked
at ups
since high school
we both
applied for that job together december
of 80 [__] one he got it
i didn't
he started as a loader from 11 to 2 at
night
and our job was just not let him go to
work like talking about it going to work
i remember two years in he told me one
time that one of the bosses at ups
pulled him aside and said hey how many
grandmothers you got
because how many of these grandmothers
died you got like 18 [__]
grandmothers that died
but hey man he stuck it out and he made
a career for himself
at ups one of the best companies in the
[__] country that's
that's a [__] fact you know
that's a long time that's 40 years at
ups
he could retire and he's like [__]
i'm taking that [__] geet i mean it's
just
it was great so we were supposed to
connect
saint patty's day but i had a lot of
[__] going on down here
and just our lives are different you
know before i came to north bergen
before i moved back to jersey i would
always go [__]
when i get back there i'm gonna see a
lot of my friends all the time
did i that was one of my expectations
that it was a cold reality you're not
going to see your friends because
everything is an hour drive
and everybody has a life everybody's got
kids everybody's going to take their
kids to college you know while they're
taking their kids to college or whatever
i'm raising a [__] eight-year-old so
it's very rough our schedules don't
you know it's sad it's [__] sad that
this is our life i'm supposed to connect
with my buddies louie and david ruiz
and all these guys from my eighth grade
class and that's been a [__]
nightmare because they can't connect
during the week i can't connect on the
weekends i'm busy with my kid
so it just didn't work out you know so
thursday night i was just sitting there
and i'm like am i gonna go up and see
you know my buddy vaneri
he always wanted to be a politician his
father and he always loved north bergen
that's one thing i can't take from
anthony he loves north bergen he knows
every crook
every every not crook every every corner
every nook of that [__] town
you know when he builds something and we
go out to dinner he always pulls over
and shows me look what we're building
here look what we're doing here he's
very proud you know and
what did he do for me growing up what
didn't he do for me growing up so
everybody said you know it's his fair up
there you know he's the one that puts it
together you should go would mean a lot
to him
but i'm like i'm gonna have to go up
there and take a bunch of [__]
pictures and i'll tell you when you
don't see people for a long time it
sucks
because they come up to you and they
want to play jeopardy you know i'm
saying like
you know you don't know who i am and i'm
like not really i don't remember you
i've been smoking dope for 40 [__]
years i've been gone for 40 [__]
years i've been gone for 30 years i
don't remember you you know
but uh
i was like i don't know let's see how i
feel on saturday
when i was at jimmy's son's game i'm
sitting there and i'm like you know what
man i haven't seen this guy glenn
i'm always complaining that i'm not
doing nothing with my life what else am
i doing and i can go for a [__] meal
so i called glenn i go what do you think
we do rudy's and then go to the [__]
carnival
he's like [__] yeah
i [__] i got in my car i said an hour
five [__] minutes i was just talking
to my niece before we were talking about
you know waves and all that [__] how it
tells you what time you're gonna get
there i'd go i get in the car i see what
time i'm gonna get there and my goal is
to beat that time
that's what my goal is i'm gonna beat
that [__] time [__] you 10 10 i'm
getting there in 48 minutes watch me so
i get in the [__] it says an hour
five i'm like [__]
i'm never gonna [__] make it up there
i call glenn i go glenn it's gonna be a
little while
i let's meet at six up at [__] rudy's
oh my god as soon as i saw
it's so weird like i haven't seen this
kid since 1993
but as soon as i saw him
it was like old magic i mean it's we
just went right back you know i was
telling my wife a long time ago
that those four kids i mentioned the
kids i grew up with a lot of them mike a
lot of i never had to tell them how to
act
like i never had to tell my friends what
to say what not to say we always
knew how to [__] go you know like we
always were in each other's [__]
universe it was the wildest thing i've
never had this
with a lot of people what i had with
them growing up but we grew up together
so we you know if i said something i
knew how to balance it off it's like how
you guys whenever i go on jre
you guys like you and rogan are so good
we should be good we've been having
little conversations [__] 25 years
about comedy this is something that
because when you it's like when people
contact and they go hey i want my friend
to be on the podcast
listen if we were doing
face-to-face podcast which we might do
on
on wednesday really yeah
i'll let you know later uh
if we start doing face-to-face podcasts
that's something different but when you
have a zoom
you could actually that's when people
hit me up and they're like hey i want
this guy to be on the podcast i don't
know
so already i'm distant with the zoom now
we're gonna even be more [__] distant
you know
i don't even know how i was talking
about i ended up talking about zoom but
what i'm trying to prove uh talk to you
about is our friendship
like i hadn't seen him in 23 years we
sat down at the [__] bar
and it was like off and running it was
like
it was no it was like we hadn't seen
each other in two weeks we just started
yakking and
you know whatever
and then uh
you know we ate and
[__] great food i had some split pea
soup
a cup and then i threw down i went up
there
and all i could think about was the
pasta fazool
and the [__] seafood salad and maybe
a piece of bread that's all i could
think about
zero calories for the [__] seafood
salad
three points for the pasta fazool and
whatever four for the piece of bread i
can't [__] lose you know what i'm
saying
i get up there i look at the [__]
board on i look at the special on the
board
i throw down the split pea soup and then
to boot
they had thin steak with shrimp scampi
over garlic mashed potatoes
you want me to repeat that again to you
[__]
thin steak like [__] medallions
with nice prawns
in shrimp scampi sauce
dipped over garlic mashed potatoes are
you [__] kidding me
what do you want me to do jump up and
down here and [__]
are you [__] kidding me
[__] threw that [__] down
i had some water the guy's like do you
want [__] desserts i'm not no i don't
want no dessert i got to watch my
[__] waist
and we shot to the [__] carnival
you know i hadn't been to hudson county
park i mean it was weird that we were
even in hudson county park
because hudson county park i [__]
lived in that [__] hudson county
park has basketball courts
fields and a bunch of land and trees
that you can hide
so when i was a kid we used to go to
albertsons it was right across the
street from hudson county park we used
to go to albertsons walk out of there
with a case of beer or a bottle of
[__]
the jug wine that red cooking wine and
we'd go right into the park get drunk
and throw rocks at [__] squirrels and
[__]
we used to get [__] up in there i've
been going ass since i was basically
in the fourth grade they used to have a
little island
with [__] paddle boats and ducks all
around you so you can float the paddle
boats and [__] let me tell you something
talking about quaaludes they used to
have
a [__] island in the middle
okay and every january night i slept at
the chinese [__] i was just talking
about i slept with the chinese
every year they would have a party on
the island in the middle of that [__]
lake and that pond it was called the
island of insanity party so it would
have to be the coldest night in january
as a friday and they would wait for the
ice to [__] freeze
they would roll kegs across the [__]
pond
dog you think i'm [__] kidding you
north ferguson's on a platinum itself
they would roll kegs across the pond
walk across with kegs of beer we could
have died guys remember when i told you
we didn't go out to play we went out to
die there you go we would walk across
the [__] ice to the island set the
kegs up and start [__] drinking and
listen i was too young it wasn't my
party it was these older guys party the
boys and one night that night that with
the [__] quaalude you ready for this
one me lubes
and this dude joe folk
[__] were at that party it was too
[__] cold
and we couldn't take it out there no
more we had eaten a quaalude and these
quails were on fire and we went to the
wing chinese restaurant they're not
there no more the wing fong was
notorious i would go in there and run
out of there without paying we would
dine and dash that's where i did my best
dine dining dash work it was at the wing
fung because the chance was too good i
couldn't [__] where i sleep but the
wingfund was mediocre who gives a [__]
about the wing fong they were right next
door to chicken delight don't cook
tonight so [__]
we would go to the wing funk and just
run out the [__] waiters would play
his own defense on us and [__] they'd be
strategically placed and [__] but i'd
pick up the tab and i would walk it and
then they'd go oh he gonna pay and i
would walk up to the count and once i
got to the count i put the tab down i'd
run out the [__] door and they would
[__] go ape [__] and then i'd come
back
i'd walk past the glass and i'd knock on
the glass and give them a
and then they'd really lose their
[__] mind it was tremendous guys i
had a childhood you know what i'm saying
so we went to the [__] we went to the
we went to the chinese place
me lubes and him we're in there [__]
coming down off the cold weather we're
freezing to death
and all of a sudden
we order the chinese food it's taking
some time to come
the first thing they throw down is the
pork fried rice
we're all on [__] gorilla biscuits
we're [__] dying
joe folk has eaten the [__] pork
fried rice now joe folk is traditionally
italian
he's got the roman nose you know good
looking dude he's got the roman nose
we're there talking about whatever music
black sabbath who the [__] knows how
cold this is outside
and all of a sudden joe i see him like
you know
he started turning into owen benjamin
you know what i'm saying like remember
when owen benjamin took the [__]
thing sarah tiana i could see that he
was like holding on to dear life and
finally after one of those things he
just dropped
into the [__] rice and the dish his
whole face everything dropped into the
dish and he started snoring dog at the
[__] place
and we're like folk
folk wake up folk folk wake up and this
[__] won't wake up we're like
folk wake the [__] up i'm hitting the
table folk wake up [__] wake up we got
to run out of here ain't got money to
pay for this [__] tab and he's like
uh
so finally we [__] get him up we
couldn't even run the [__] out i
couldn't even dine and dash we had to
actually pay for the [__] thing
tremendous quaaludes were [__] great
quailers were tremendous i loved them
that [__] wolf of wall street brought
me the [__] back you can see i got some
extra pep in my step on a monday [__]
morning the 11th of october before we go
any further
i want to talk to you about better
health [__] tremendous you understand
me you can see i'm doing a lot better
with better health better help is
therapy for the 21st century
it's professional
therapy all online it's fast
start talking to your therapist in less
than 48 hours there's no messing around
you get a good match they'll put you
with a licensed therapist who is right
for you if you don't like your match
it's easy and free to change therapists
if needed listen
better help has helped me
[__] by leaps and bounds you guys saw
how i was acting here for the first six
months of the podcast i was confused
i had
[__] fog i didn't know what was going
i had brain fog i didn't even have
[__] covert but regardless better
help help me uh i got a counselor named
dana she walked me step by step she
gives me homework
they're having a page to to go over your
anxiety check out better health you're
not going to get a great therapist right
now they're all taken up they're all
busy they're all booked up why
everybody's going through something
right now
contact better help go to betterhelp.com
go to betterhelp.com diaz i'm going to
get you 10 off your first month listen
it's affordable you don't have to be a
fancy ass new yorker to pay for this
it's all remote no waiting room
no appointments no driving you could
have a flexible flexible schedule day or
night you could do phone or video calls
i do video calls and now you can send
messages to your therapist anytime and
they'll get back to you in between
sessions
better help is 100 percent remote and
available worldwide you don't have to
live in a big city and be fancy trust me
if you have somebody
outside your world to talk to it's easy
to schedule it's affordable and they'll
take a load over your shoulders off of
your shoulders over a million people
have taken care of their mental health i
i did i had and i never thought i would
do something like this but i did and
i'll tell you what guys i feel a lot
[__] better so go to betterhelp.com
diaz again that's betterhelp.com
[__] diaz and get 10 percent off your
first month and i guarantee you'll tweet
me and go joey i feel a lot better you
can tell with me the proof is in the
pudding just put on a podcast from six
months ago i'm stuttering i'm [__]
all confused and [__] i'm a lot better
now go to betterhelp.com
views code word joey or diaz and get 10
off your first month with better health
back to the [__] carnival in the
[__] story so last night we ate the
[__] food and i go you know what
everything against me didn't want to go
to this thing i'm like i don't want to
walk around my knees going to hurt
there's not going to be any parking
spots
you know i was giving myself stinking
thinking
every [__] reason not to go there but
i had to go
i had to go because it was time i had to
see some people
i wanted to see some people and you know
what man seeing old friends is always
good for the [__] soul i don't give a
[__] what anybody tells you
so
i got my car
i called my friend's son i go i need
some [__] parking he goes pull into
the [__] carnival and park with all
the commissioners and [__]
and that's exactly what i [__] did
and i walked out there i saw my nephew
anthony junior
i saw my niece kelly and alyssa
i saw so many [__] people at the
cornwall i saw my [__] i saw
kelly's son axel i i held him we danced
to the [__] music i didn't eat
anything at the carnival no cotton candy
or nothing i saw somebody's water that
was closed and i stole it because i had
[__] cotton mountain [__] but they
were drinking they were having a great
[__] time and i'll tell you man i saw
a lot of old friends i saw joe focaracho
who fell into the [__]
pork fried rice i saw lisa gallo i saw
eddie connors
i saw a lot of my [__] friends man
but i could see that
i made my friend anthony [__] happy
you know i don't have the opportunity to
do that from time to time you know i got
my own life
but i could tell i made his day and like
i told you guys sometimes making
somebody's day is is [__] great it's
a great feeling
you know uh then the [__] craziest
part of the night came
when i'm standing there minding my own
business and the [__] mayor came up
to me
i looked over and i saw him walking to
me and i go oh no
the mayor of north bergen is the
sweetheart of a [__] guy and you know
what he's turning that [__] town
around
you know i came i grew up with the
administration before him
so i was always very leery of mayor
sacko but i got to be honest with you
the proof is in the pudding look at the
[__] town
the town looks [__] great
crime is low yeah they found somebody
dead behind my grammar school a couple
weeks ago but somebody killed him and
put him there it wasn't like a north
perigan [__] dude or whatever
uh
you know it's uh yeah no i don't
it's uh great to see he's been a [__]
mayor there for close to
30 years
30 [__] years and i remember him from
grammar school
he used to yell at me all the time in
grammar school because he was one of the
principals or something at lincoln
school lincoln schools where the the
bottom floor the kids are a little
like when we were kids the kids would be
tied up they would bring them to the
games all tied up and [__] you know so
uh it was just it's it's a weird area
that area there i i really enjoy myself
it's the [__] buck wild area north
bergen lincoln school
but i remember like being in the eighth
grade and yelling at me for something i
was tight with one of the kids from
[__] uh lincoln school that's dead
now
dan rego his brother was there last
night
it was great to see him uh
when the man came over to me it was a
real [__] hot you know like
i'm not a politician type of [__]
dude you know
but
he came over he said he saw the movie
that he was proud of me i shook his hand
and then while the other commissioners
came over i started talking to him he
was very nice
and then uh
they said if i wanted to take the family
picture and i'm like
yeah why not i took the family picture
with them
i said thank you and they said you know
we'll see you soon and
it was just a great feeling guys i
needed to do that man i just needed to
i had a good week i went over to i saw
two baseball games out i went to see the
the boston
yankee game tuesday night
i went out wednesday night to see the
dodger
st louis game
i went to jiu jitsu this week i went to
acupuncture
you know i'm getting out more and this
is what i needed you know the first year
i just wanted to come here i i stuck to
my plan
i just wanted to get to know my
neighborhood see my neighbors meet new
people
and just see what the [__] is going on
here you know i don't know what the [__]
was going on people were trying to blow
up my phone making me go here pulling me
down ten thousand different directions i
couldn't do it i just wanted to stay
close to home
and see what the [__] this area was
about you know see what this is all
about and i'm happy i did i'm a better
person i feel [__] better
you guys keep telling me i'm looking
better i look at myself and just see an
old [__] man i'm getting ugly by the
day
i'm getting grayed by the [__] day
but listen i got nothing but heart and
balls for you [__] and nothing
but love for you guys for the uh you
know the way you treat me
so i'm here just spilling my [__]
guts every week
telling you how about about how i feel
you know so
it was great and i needed to do that
last night and i a lot of years
hit me up with emails and stuff on
patreon or whatever
and you're like joey we don't know what
to do get the [__] out of the house
you know get the [__] out of the house i
am so sick
of this [__] and what it did to me
you know it burned me it put fear in my
heart i don't do i look like the [__]
guy that's ever been fearful of anything
for christ's sake i put a guy in the
trunk of a [__] car i went to [__]
prison i get up on stage and talk to
[__] strangers for a living
i get up on stage by myself there's not
a guy with a base standing behind me or
a [__] cowbell
i'm up there by myself you want to talk
about being [__] scared shitless
so fear has never been an issue with me
i've never been scared of [__] i don't
give a frenchman's [__]
i hate being [__] scared so this blew
me out of the [__] water situation
the last [__] 18 months so i [__]
had it like i [__] had it and i've
been trying to make a move for weeks
i've been trying to make little moves if
i could have found somebody to go to
black crows with me i would have gone to
the black crows i just didn't want to go
to black crows walking there by myself
people like [__] you're in movies and
[__] you're hanging out by yourself what
are you you don't wear deodorant what do
you got to have
you know so
i'm trying i'm gonna go out a little
more and this week i'm gonna go out last
week i went out three nights
this week i'm gonna go for four [__]
nights and what does that mean
that i'm going to a bar now just get the
[__] out of the house at night my
toughest part of the day guys between
you and i is between six and nine
yeah you can pick up the guitar that's
20 minutes 30 minutes
it's a struggle after dinner till
[__]
nine o'clock
because i won't turn the tv on until
[__] nine o'clock lately i've been
turning on a little earlier to watch
games and whatnot but i won't turn the
[__] tv on until nine
so you know what it's better if i get
the [__] out i just can't sit there
anymore
so i talk to my daughter i talk to my
wife
i'm gonna make some moves during the
week i'm gonna be home by ten you guys
know me i gotta be home by ten to take
my ten o'clock dump
drink my [__] tea and take my little
[__] pilly poo
or if not everything falls apart for me
so
i just gotta live a little more there's
nothing you know i thought because i
wasn't doing stand-up
that i wasn't going out like i'm you're
not doing stand-up you shouldn't go out
[__] that
i'm gonna start going out more start
doing little things you know i talked to
a friend of mine brian he manages
[__] guns and roses
he called me the other day tell me he
watched the movie and stuff
and we had a pretty good conversation
you know let me tell you something guns
and roses was on the road
for nine weeks
without a [__] hipka hiccup
did you know that
not a hiccup no nobody got covered
nobody got uh
nobody got sick
none of the roadies got [__] sick
nobody got nothing
and we had a nice talk about it
we were just uh
saying how the [__] you know
what was talking about
brian you were talking about
yeah
he
i think half of this [__] [__] is
[__] dude i was on a wedding
saturday dude
no masks no masks doing live sound again
yeah i don't know what the [__] is going
on
nine [__] weeks nobody got sick
you know they performed for anybody from
20 000 people
to 80 000 a night
nobody got sick the festivals they did
nobody got sick nobody got sick at these
big music festivals
you know i don't know what the [__]
going on again i'm just a [__]
follower like you guys i'm just
listening to what the [__] they tell me
but you know if if i didn't have coven
after the premiere i'm not going to get
covered
if i don't have covert after last night
after taking pictures and talking to
people and
i'm not going to have coven
so i don't know what the [__] going on
i mean i like to just get it at this
point just to get it over with because
my friend had got it and he said it was
just a [__] colt
he goes oh
yeah he goes i was stuffy for three days
and then he goes it went away because i
broke a temperature
one [__] day so if it means that
compared to staying in and not i gotta
[__] go out i'm a social [__]
butterfly believe it or not i like
seeing people i like talking to people i
mean i don't want to see 25 000 [__]
people
but i like seeing people i like talking
to people i don't like [__] you know
depression starts when you stay in i
don't
i won't tell you people i was depressed
i will tell you that after the pain pill
medic uh debacle
the pain and everything i did get a
little down on myself for a few months
there
but it wasn't because i was staying in
it was because i just i i
thought i had made a mistake with the
knee surgery you know but i don't know i
was a little touched but it wasn't
from me staying in if anything
i am a [__] depression
uh
i go the other way it's like people say
jiu jitsu is
the opposite of social distancing i am
the opposite of letting depression hit
me i am very aware of it i i saw
somebody who had it and i know the rules
number one rule get out of bed
get in that [__] shower and get out
of the house
that's the avoiding of depression i
don't give a [__] if it's sun out i
don't give a [__] if it's raining out i
don't give a [__] if it's snowing out
those are the [__] rules of
depression you want to beat depression
those are the [__] three things you
have to [__] do how do i know because
i had bounced depression growing up i
didn't have a mom remember i didn't have
a dad remember i was a [__] loser
remember i was an addict remember so i
had bouts with it so as soon as i would
feel it coming on i knew exactly how to
[__] treat it shower
get the [__] out of bed getting out of
bed is the most important thing i know
there's people that tell you that can't
get better out of bed listen guys for
years i didn't feel like getting out of
bed but i knew all i had to do was make
it to the [__] shower
if you can make it to the shower you're
going to be fine and i know you
[__] can make it to the shower
unless you got a broken ankle or you got
a [__]
lump on your head or your [__]
something you make it to the shower you
jump in that [__] shower and you get
the [__] out of the house so i know for
a fact i wasn't depressed i was just
i think i was down over the move
over uh
you know the ending of california you
know that was big 23 [__] years to
[__] leave the place
you know i didn't see it i didn't feel
it as i was
going through it but looking back now
i could see how that bothered me a
little bit the [__] that went on
with the cancelled [__] that you know
they went out all those things
affected me in a way or two after now i
really don't give a [__] about any of
those things
i'm back with a [__] vengeance
i'm back like aerosmith in 76.
i don't give a [__] it's just a matter
of time before we go off the [__]
plantation here but i will tell you one
thing
i will tell you something that's
i had to stop smoking joints last week
like i was like why am i because every
night i would go out there and smoke a
joint
and i would smoke like half the joint
i'm like i'm sick of smoking this
already it's starting to bother my
[__] thing that's why i busted out
the freeze pipe
that freeze pipe [__] works
tremendously but i started using a
little pipe the one that mike gave me
the the red lion cbd
dog i fill that [__] up i put a
little keefe on top of it
i smoked that [__] and i got to
tell you something guys
i'm up there eating m m's 10 minutes
later so
it works i don't even have to smoke a
joint anymore that's how much i've
enjoyed
giving myself a [__] tolerance break
on this thc i don't have to smoke joints
anymore
i was smoking half joints and [__]
throwing them in a box
and just saving them and i said why am i
doing this i opened them all up
you know and i [__] uh
that's it i'm down to a [__] pipe now
i'm up to about 500 milligrams at night
before i go to sleep
that's a lot of [__] love but dog i
get [__] elevated
like i have a hard time walking upstairs
but that's how i like it
i don't want to wake up in the middle of
night
i don't want to do nothing when you
[__] when you're [__] tapering
the biggest complaint is [__] his uh
insomnia how people can't sleep
i'm the type of dude i can't deal with
[__] insomnia i don't like it
i get angry and then i get angry and i
[__] stay up
so i can't deal with [__] insomnia so
i don't give a [__] listen i'm tapering
i'm doing a great job i probably got
another month left
it's gonna be a quick [__] paper you
know
uh
but
i'm feeling great i'm happy i went up to
that [__] carnival
and i'm happy i'm headed in the right
direction uh
there was no [__] magic pill here
it was sleep
therapy
and just sticking to my [__] goals
writing
you know
i get down on myself from time to time
and i'm like wait a second
three days a week four days a week i'm
on a [__] phone
making notes writing a book with a you
know like i don't
i never see what i'm actually doing like
i never really take it
in a big manner but i gotta be honest
with you i'm making things [__]
happen not that i even you know i'm i
still suck on the guitar
you know at least i'm
i'm back in my [__] trend i'm back in
acupuncture i'm back in jiu jitsu you
know within a month i'm gonna start
going to classes for right now i'm just
taking privates with them once a week
we had a plan you know we devised a
little plan for each other i think this
week coming up will be my fourth private
and then i'm going to start going uh
maybe on the weekend for an hour when
i'm [__] around i mean you know
it's going to be an involvement and then
from there i'm going to start going for
the classes i'm going to go to my friend
dave baton
because i have
arthritis in my left knee
and i got i don't want to start taking
shots i don't want to start taking i was
going to do the surgery in january but i
don't want to go through the pain pill
thing again so i'm just going to there's
a way to work on the knee and to work on
the arthritis
so i talked to him saturday and he said
to come down one day next week
and we'll start rehabbing it and this is
what we do i'm a [__] old man what do
you want from me guys what do you want
me to do lay down and get in my [__]
old man chair and not see me again i
plan on slinging dick till i'm 70.
that's the going [__] rate right now
i thought about it about a week ago and
i'm like what am i thinking about
retiring i'm not do because i can't
retire you know me i'm like a [__]
shark i can't stop [__] moving i
really can't guys
i don't want to retire yet i'm still too
young to [__] retire everything's
still working i still wake up with a
heart on what am i thinking about
retiring for you retire when you stop
waking up with a [__] heart on you
know unless i unless i'm taking [__]
viagra my sleep or blue chew in my
[__] sleep so i'm waking up with
tremendous [__] heart on so
everything is kumsi kumsa here on uncle
joey's joint i appreciate
you [__] supporting me
every monday and wednesday
we try to do the best we can we try to
come at you with [__] innovative
conversation and chitter chatter if you
don't look at it that way i don't know
what the [__] to tell you this is
innovating for me just being able to
[__] with you [__] for an
hour by myself it's like kind of doing a
stand-up routine just not so funny but
who gives a [__] there's a ton of people
you're paying 35 to see and they'll make
you laugh one time
this is free and at least we're having a
good time or at least i'm having a
[__] good time by telling you my
[__] story here
but everything was great i had a great
[__] weekend
i'm happy i went up to that [__]
carnival happy i got to see my friends
you know i talked to glenn this morning
and uh we text we're gonna do it once a
[__] month just get together
you know he'll come down here one night
we'll do dinner at a local restaurant
and i'll do the same if i get three
friends to do that
my nights are taken up you know they
don't have to be fancy schmancy
restaurants
we could just go for a [__] slice of
pizza i don't give a [__] about that
[__]
it's just getting back out there
reconnecting with my friends
and uh i'll maybe try to get him on the
podcast one time
we got some great [__] stories we
were laughing
our asses off last night there was a kid
there
and uh last night his name is john great
[__] guy i know him since the eighth
grade too
and he came up to me last night with
glenn he goes remember the time
we went over to the bronx she wanted to
get drugs and i'm like oh my god i can't
believe you remembered that
we were walking up the stairs in this
[__] creepy building
and he's like where are we going you
know he was really naive he wasn't a
drug addict like i am
i just made him come over with me we had
a car and they were with us we might as
well take the ride to the bronx
so i parked the car in the bronx and i
take him into this [__] dilapidated
[__] building
and as we're walking up the stairs he
won't stop with the where are we going
where are we going why are we here
you know what are we doing and i'm like
dog
relax i'm gonna get you laid there's a
hooker we're gonna go see there was no
hooker but i'll never forget he looked
at me and he goes what and make love to
a strange woman i go yeah make love to a
strange woman who gives a [__] there was
no hooker i was going to see some chick
the cop up there in the bronx but i saw
him last night i told him that line is
coco
i cannot believe you remember that day
and i go dog
there's not much i [__] forgot you
know from those i still remember all
those funny lines that was the
hanging out with those guys was the
[__] foundation of my comedy career
and i realized that last night
and that's why i'm grateful to those
[__] with all my heart
but with that said i had a great [__]
time this weekend i hope you guys had a
great time
i got some weird [__] news i'm trying
to put the screening up for the patreon
people
to take them to go see the [__] many
saints in newark
after all the bad reviews i don't think
they'll want to go see it now anyway but
it's a great movie what i wanted to tell
you is that
like september 18th i called amc
freehold and i'm like hey man
can i watch the movie they're like well
before you do anything before we can
even talk to you
you have to go on the website and
go through corporate and fill out this
paperwork
don't get back in a few days no problem
i [__] fill out the paperwork my wife
downloads and i fill it out i send it
back
a day goes by two days go by three days
go by
nobody calls
i call up the [__] thing i call up a
regional sales office in kansas city
i leave a message nobody [__] calls
me back okay i call freehold 14 again
some lady answers the phone i tell him
my dilemma she goes
send me the paperwork
she gave me a [__] email address i
had my wife forward it over to her
okay i'll get this done i'll call you
back in a few days well a [__] week
went by and she never got back to me
you know i want to do this with the
patreon people you know i told him i'd
do it this is what i want to do so
i call again some pimple [__] face
kid answers how do i know he had pimples
i don't know but i could just hear his
pimples on the [__] phone he was
confused hello i i don't know what
you're talking about
i spoke to lisa whatever her [__]
name is
she's supposed to get back to me
yeah and then he hung up on me
so i called back and talked to some
other guy and nobody could find my
paperwork and i don't know what the
[__] going on so i called the [__]
uh
jn's whatever
amc and [__] uh eating down the one i
went to
to the q a with my buddy chuck
and they're [__] saying they'll get
back to me that was a week i told him i
was just there last week i know i could
rent out the theater you know it was a
monday
if it needs to be monday guy goes yeah
probably need to be monday because with
james bond there's going to be a lot of
people here this weekend
so probably have to be monday or
wednesday i'll go okay
i call back nothing i call back freehold
nothing i get pissed off so i finally go
maybe that guy did the q a for and
eatontown and and the uh amc and [__]
uh mountainside maybe he could help me i
mean he does him you know so i called
him up
and i go hey man can i talk to you about
something i need a problem here
uh can you help me out getting an amc
theater in the freehold and he goes are
you [__] kidding me goes i got two
more dates at the free at the amc and
then we're out of there
i go what are you talking about he goes
bro amc
fired everybody up at the top he goes i
don't even have anybody to call
he just went on on and on about what was
going on with amc and
how we couldn't [__] they don't get
back to you the eatontown one fired the
whole [__] cleaning staff
and they're making the managers clean
the [__] theaters can you believe
that [__] so
i was like in shock i didn't [__]
know
so he told me to try the i think there's
another theater in
the red bank and lowe's
so i called them so i'm waiting for a
call back from them tomorrow
and then we'll figure out what the
[__] going on let me tell you how bad
the theater business is
i heard they did a screening for the
sopranos for the many saints in
orange
east orange west orange
the movie theater had been closed for
the pandemic
people were watching the movie that
opened up just for the many saints in
newark
they opened it up with that movie you
know now they're going to stay open
i heard while people were sitting there
they could feel mice
eating at their feet and [__] because
the theater had been closed so long
the theater's been closed for [__]
close to 16 months so
[__]
hey you check up on it but mice you know
the what's that while the cat's away the
mice will play you know
that's the [__] uh
that's it people bring pop you know how
much [__] popcorn spins and goes
under a carpet or whatever so what do
you think people are eating at their
feet
you're watching the movie can you
imagine watching a movie and something's
[__] eating at your feet i would run
the [__] out of that if i saw a mouse or
a [__] rat in a movie theater but
that's what's going on so i'm sorry
if you're on patreon you've been waiting
i've been [__] waiting too so give me
a couple days
it's gonna have to be on a weekday so
that
scratch is half of you but the funny
thing was i told my wife i can't believe
what's going on she goes
you didn't know that you [__] idiot
that these things are basically
they're basically staying open by a life
threat he told me the guy chuck goes
listen they don't even make money on the
movies no more they're in business to
sell popcorn and m m's that's it but
anyway i know you guys got a busy monday
i love you [__] have a great
week and i'll be back wednesday with a
new movie review and a great guest i
love you [__]
and now for a word from my [__]
sponsors
all right you bad [__] i want
to thank you for watching today on a
monday morning
i didn't know what the [__] i was
talking about today but i surely did
have a good [__] time
talking about quaaludes the wolf of wall
street you know but anyway the joint is
brought to you by better health better
help is therapy for the 21st century
listen we've had a rough go of it the
last two years
better help is professional therapy
online it's fast you start talking to
your therapist less than 48 hours try
looking for a therapist today you won't
find one because they're all booked up
what do you think you're the only one
who's got problems everybody's got
problems
i have him i contacted betterhelp i
spoke to a council a therapist named
dana and she was tremendous the most
important thing about therapy is that
sometimes
you need someone you feel like you could
talk to somebody who gets you and that's
not in your circle
this is the way to go it's affordable
you don't have to be fancy to afford
this and financial aid is available
it's so it's all remote no more waiting
room
flexible schedule you can do it on the
phone or video calls whenever you want
morning late evening and now you can
send messages to your therapist and
they'll get back to you in between
sessions better help
is 100 remote and available worldwide
okay
you could get quality therapy on here so
start today you've been feeling a little
weird lately trust me it helps to have
someone outside your world to talk to
it's easy
affordable and you could easy to
schedule and you could take a load off
your shoulders i did over a million
people have taken charge of their mental
health join them with better help plus
they got a great offer for you
visit betterhelp.com
diaz for 10
off your first month that's
betterhelp.com
[Music]
diaz b-e-t-t-e-r
help h-e-l-p
dot com slash diaz betterhelp.com
diaz
get better help and start living
happy i am you guys can tell
the joint is also brought to you by
manscape it's the fall
and your nuts still smell like a [__]
dump
because you got [__] hair all over
the place you filthy [__] it's
manscape time it's manscape performance
package time 4.0 [__] get the
lawnmower 4.0 trimmer with the ceramic
blade so precise you only cut the hairs
no no no [__] nut bag
no [__] performance stick none of
that [__] the lawnmower is waterproof
and it's got an led night you could
shave in the [__] duck if you want to
or you could trim your ball sack in the
dark the performance package also
includes the weed whacker and the
earhead trimmer the crop preserver ball
deodorant which is magnifique and the
crop reviver you can put on your nut
sack it smoothens it out you can put it
under your eyes nobody will know nothing
after a rough night of eating [__]
the performance boxer briefs and a
travel bag to carry it all the
performance package 4.0 is global
get it worldwide from singapore to
africa to australia to uk
i love manscape you guys know that
because i've been with them for like 10
[__] years
i'm a clean dude i like my [__] to
smell good
i like my balls to smell good and i like
my dick to smell good even though i'm 58
and i got problems it has a weird smell
to it it don't really matter crop
preserver and the crop revival will take
care of all those orders all those odors
but it all starts by you go to
manscape.com showy again that's
manscape.com
joey
20 off worldwide shipping
no more stinky hairs with manscape
all right manscape.com
joey and your nuts will be [__]
magnifique
the joint is also brought to you by
liquid iv listen
if you're not taking vitamins to staying
dehydrated
you're you're [__] bound to get sick
it's flu season support your immune
system with the proper hydration
and vitamins
one stick of liquid iv in just 16 ounces
of water that'll put a hem in your
[__] skirt it'll hydrate you faster
and more efficiently than water alone i
take it with me to the gym i drink a
pre-protein drink but when i go to the
gym
i pop a liquid iv and i'll tell you it's
tremendous it's healthier than any of
those overpriced sugary sports drinks
there's no artificial flavors and
there's less sugar than an apple you
can't beat it it's made with clean
ingredients
non-gmo vegan and free of gluten and
they're supporting front line workers so
do me a favor
you need to be dehydrated you need to be
healthy start with liquid iv and you can
get it at walmart or get it delivered
and i'll get you 25 off when you go to
liquidity.com use joey at checkout
that's 25 off anything you order
get better hydration
today using promo code joey at liquid
iv.com i love you [__] i want
to thank liquid iv
i want to thank better help and i want
to thank manscape but most importantly i
want to thank you savages for having my
back
and for being here every monday and
wednesday i love you stay black
there you go [__]
[Music]
foreign
you